you probably know it
you work for a store,
for example
and before your shift starts
you have to be there 10 minutes or 15 minutes in advance
but this time is not included in the schedule
and you will not be paid this time either
is that actually allowed
well actually not
both the court of limburg think so
as the court of north holland
in business it was about conflict
between the employee and the employer
in which the employee did not just want to sit unpaid
wait for the employer
for example,
finished counting the cash register
or wait until the service was for them
was done and came down
to the break rooms for work you do
you get paid
even if you are a minor
therefore also falls under work
waiting until, for example,
the cash register has been counted
or wait for the store to open
although that every time
but of course few minutes goes
it builds up over time
if the employer thinks it is important that you are ready
to go to work
you cannot dispose of that time and that time
so you can be paid